if you had there's a lot of blow job
stuff if you had the flexibility to blow
yourself would you do it would i do it
of course anybody who says no to that
i'm saying i might do it once there's no
way i have the ability i'm like never
gonna give it a shot yeah you're gonna
try and be like all right this is weird
um
but if it's awesome then i'm doing all
the time all the time right and like
what if everybody knew i'd be like yeah
can you blow yourself i would be showing
people how i do it like how would you do
it how did you go about it i mean a lot
of spit and
more like physically like oh would you
like well i tried you know when i was a
kid and i just kind of like only that
just trying to like
he went on his back with his legs over
his head
i'm imagining that i'm wildly flexible
in this scenario
so i'm just like i think like i can just
like grab my legs and just [ __ ] you
know
yeah yeah so you're like you're not even
brought your face [ __ ] yeah of course
would you rather
[ __ ]
a chick who's banged a thousand dudes
and there or a chick who's banged one
animal
dude thousand dudes not even a question
bang's an animal i don't want to know
that i can't follow an animal true
you don't want to know that she's like
i'm sorry about i don't want to say this
this german shepherd this german [ __ ]
rearranged my [ __ ] it's always a german
shepherd always but what if you know why
they listen to commands they are good
they're hot dogs they're good dogs
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like a
disturbingly good dog
[Laughter]
oh there it is
are you watching your dog hump yeah dude
my dog you've been watching when you
pull her at the park she's like
still trying to get it she's a lady so i
could be wrong i don't know what about
this for a fancy you go down to tijuana
the donkey show there it is sweet
senoritas just got murdered by a donkey
literally but yeah the pussy's been
ripped apart
by a burro yeah you're sitting there
you're like i can take you from here
yeah i can then she goes give me 15
minutes while i sit on this ice pack
all right
i can respond i can save her you go let
me go you know 1000 dudes i'm gonna grab
the buick
i'm gonna swinging this around i can't
believe this worked out
i can't believe this donkey show worked
out who thought i found love this is
gonna sound crazy my friend's gonna love
you
she's good with animals
[Laughter]
she's bilingual
a thousand dudes thousand dudes thousand
dicks descend upon you tonight we suck
in hell yeah that's a tough one yeah
thousand dogs i don't know man i feel
like at that point one dog everybody
gets a dog yeah but i feel like at that
point she's got she's got a throwing
motion that's true you love [ __ ] dude
i'm sorry because right off the
fingertips knows where the balls go
every time it's a vet she's a wildly vet
a lady with an animal i don't know what
she's gonna pick up and put in her that
could be good though no you want a wild
card around the house no i don't i don't
want her to be like hey by the way your
tennis racket you're at the mall walking
past petsmart she's like
no she just grabs your arm you'll stop
it
we're not going to the dog tracks
it's a labradoodle
yeah what type of animal [ __ ] it
sex with an animal you could get a
richer gear situation that'll be durable
that's easily fallable she shoved in
germany
can't fight
[Laughter]
animal no i mean you got to go with
you've got to go with a thousand dongs
tell you man you get that malcolm
gladwell [ __ ]
ten thousand hours true
wow that's how you know
yeah i like i appreciate what you're
saying i agree
should you lock a dog out of a room
while you're having sex yes especially
if it's a bull mastiff
i was having sex with my wife one time
doggy style i thought he'd appreciate it
and
and i
you know like we're older and we
miscalculated height and i popped out
and my dog saw my dick and was like what
is that
and it's got all those pheromones on it
and the dogs chasing it and i'm fighting
this [ __ ] thing i got this 130 pound
beast on the bed i'm fighting the dog
if a guy matches with his best friend's
sister on tinder should he pursue it um
yeah just like don't tell him about it
but like because if because if she
matched then she wants to [ __ ] him too
so like
i don't know are guys like offended by
that do you guys not most guys don't
want their friend to [ __ ] their sister
really yeah believe it or not yeah but i
felt i felt my friends brothers and they
didn't care
and they don't care
well i don't know i'm not still friends
with the girls that i [ __ ] their
brothers
i actually became friends with this girl
one time just to [ __ ] her brother
and then i did let her know that her
brother had a really big day
these are the reasons why you don't want
your friends and your brothers to [ __ ]
i don't get it
would you [ __ ] a porn star if afterwards
she had to hold the press conference on
your performance
absolutely not
absolutely not it already happened
yeah yeah please explain to the folks at
home local radio station jones yeah baby
jones she this is after she yeah yeah i
had been with gronk and uh she yeah she
wanted me to post a photo of us at
dinner and stuff like that i obviously
declined because i didn't want anyone
knowing that we were out together other
than the news station who ended up
getting her on the next morning at eight
a.m to talk about my performance what
did she say she dogged them oh
brought me to a crappy restaurant like
you couldn't have she paid for rent she
might they went to red lobster dude took
her to red
lobster was it a bad performance or was
she just right no no the the the
her boyfriend or partner at the time
yeah bizarro land was calling on the
phone the whole time it was it was one
of the most awkward experiences i've
ever been through a big component as to
why i'm like no i'm not posting anything
about being associated with this
and then the following morning i mean it
was when you get dragged off i got no no
i got my phone was off the hook the next
morning and we were playing the chicago
blackhawks that night and it was an
important game because we were in a
playoff race and i'm getting the call
and then all of a sudden i read the text
from the guy at the radio station being
like hey bibby's on and and she's
carving you and my heart is just
well i'm just hoping the team doesn't
hear about it which i'm sure that they
did but what can you do if you're
getting graded on your bad performance
as long as you're physical that night
biz that's all we care about
we're glad you we got you you held some
of that aggression for the game night
rather than exerting it with baby jones
and uh you think all the employees here
didn't want to get called into bars 2
radio in port noise on imagine b.b jones
carving your caulk up on on phoenix area
scottsdale radio yeah that was a tough
scene wwf any very rare for these
ridiculous questions that someone has a
real life story yeah it's biz
yeah that happened 100 25 years old in
college yeah nowadays i need a [ __ ]
roman sponsor and a seattle sponsor and
i'd give it a whirl fair enough get the
waiver fair enough the old lady would
you rather pee
every time you stand up or poop
every time you sit down well i gotta be
honest with you i genuinely feel like i
absolutely have prostate cancer because
i have to pee
24 7. the amount of pee that's going to
come out of my body right now is as soon
as this is over i'm going to wet my
pants so i would say every time i'm
standing i feel like i'm have to pee and
to be honest dude every time i sit down
the fart that i ripped the fart and you
know what
you should even though he seems like a
nice guy i would get rid of this
cameraman because you got to know when
chrissy cares in the building you start
rolling because i farted out of the top
of my ass crack how
on top of the cracker is very rare and
you missed it
so shame on you where's the homeless
pimp
it goes up yes it went up it was like a
[ __ ] jed
it was like a jazz tune beethoven was
like i heard that i'd rather i'd rat
because i know what it feels like to
every time i stand up have to pee
because it's i have prostate cancer aka
chlamydia
so i'll say so i know what that's like
so i'll say every time i sit down i i
poop because that's really not that bad
because you just wear a diaper my ass is
fat enough anyway you can't see it i
have a lunch lady ass
would you rather watch her come on guys
would you rather watch your dad [ __ ] a
hundred year old man
or watch your mother kill someone watch
my mother kill someone come on that's
ava
ovio to the max watch your mother kill
someone obviously
oh that wasn't even that you would do
anyway you know you would have a problem
like looking at your mom like like i
look at her in a different way the way
you discover like the pictures of her
trip to italy from college you're like
wow you look so cool back then
same [ __ ] you'd be like oh wow for sure
it's different
but like not in a worse way
that's you need to couple that with
another positive would you rather watch
your mom kill someone or would you
rather yeah we get like 10 you know 50
bucks a week for life but you have to go
down somewhere to get it every week
all right
you can turn any movie into a porno with
the same cast from the movie which movie
are you picking should we just go old
school and just see star wars you know
every everybody wants to see chewbacca
get it on come on
like that
everybody wants a pony with chewbacca
disney's gonna kill me
[Laughter]
would you rather anyone be naked all the
time or clothes all the time i want
everybody to be clothed cause i
definitely don't want to see you naked
and your friend with that pink face and
pink dick
i don't want that tropical dick [ __ ] no
i want your clothes on if it face pink
can you imagine what a wing wing look
like i can't call it no dick is still
growing
what's the weirdest thing you've jerked
off to probably maybe rachel ray
is that too uh on the nose is that too
specific
well you know when you're watching
something you're like i guess i'm gonna
jerk off like you just see a lady it's
uh
you know isn't that weird we all have
that i don't know if ladies have that
you know but uh yeah i'll just be like
oh the westminster dog show this lady
with the uh with the poodle is looking
pretty good then you rub one out it's
like he decides for you it's like all
right i guess okay yeah it's his call if
you got ten thousand dollars a day for
every day you didn't masturbate how many
days could you last i didn't go like 30
days what no [ __ ] shot all right fine
two days
should you lock a dog out of the room
when you're having sex no let them in
put a little peanut butter in the middle
threesome
include your dog that's your kid are
there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate funerals tragedies religious
holidays etcetera god how do you cry
without calling
no i don't yeah that's mandatory getting
up and beating off his mandatory did you
jerk off on it
three thousand times
how many grown men would it take to kill
the grizzly player with their beard one
me end off
i'll [ __ ] double leg him elbows
facing for him he wouldn't like to take
the hamlet and [ __ ] his [ __ ] would you
rather sit on a cake and eat a dick or
sit on a dick and eat a cake i'm gonna
say sit on a dick and eat a cake that's
that's pretty much that's a no-brainer
but sitting on a cake and eating a dick
is just that's a good story to tell
that's a fun story so you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm taking it back i'm
gonna say sit on a cake and eat a dick
there's something about that that i mean
listen i'm coming out of it with a yeast
infection but it's it'll be a fun story
would you rather date a nine with a
really annoying voice or a four with the
sexiest voice ever
four baby fours all day call me john
daly because i'm getting the goddamn
fours baby why wouldn't you want a four
with a sexy ass voice then when you're
out of town the phone sex is just
amazing you just you're picturing pam
anderson but she's over there like hey
daddy how was your show tonight and
you're like this is amazing because if
you're dating the nine she's like that
was your show tonight and you're like is
this [ __ ] chuck liddell on the phone
who am i talking to i'm going fours all
day baby fours
get
divorced i don't know force force horse
king's cup we've all been there
how much money would it take to be
verbally to verbally belittle a [ __ ]
in front of a crowd of 100 people what's
the race if it's like white male [ __ ]
i think i would you know we could find a
number but like if it was like black
like female crippled [ __ ] i don't
think i'd do it
we'd have to be like leave the country
money i don't need that smoke
white male [ __ ] like cocky you know
what i mean you got tattoos on you got
aviators and [ __ ] you go all right
people will be looking at like what did
the [ __ ] do
if you could go to any sporting event
ever which would it be you know
sometimes the people
uh we had matt damon on the show and he
was talking about this uh soccer game
football game that he went to in
argentina and it sounded so crazy like
so bucket list like a thing that you
have to do formula one race in monaco
that looks like a lot of fun and i bet
the partying around there at that time
and in that area is amazing so
i'll go with uh f1 race monaco bro i can
suck my own dick
yeah i swear to god hold on i'll show
you right now okay yeah
[Laughter]
come on over here
guys welcome to brookwood episode three
itunes spotify
this was the day the rock unfollowed
not a lot because my uncle's on top of
me
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon